DEBUTS TONIGHT,
19-YEAR-OLD, POSSIBLE TO PLAY J
FOR  WILLIAM NYLANDER
BRINGS THAT BACK FOR RIELLY,
NYLANDER HAS THREE POWER PLAY
GOALS ON THE LEAD. LEAFS MOVE
IT LOOKS SIMULTANEOUS TO ME.
YOUR OPINION IS YOU,
HE'S WATCHING THE MONDAY STORE
GOT SHOVED DOWN, CENTERED
AND STILL NO ONE N, HERE IN THE
PERIOD.
LONG PASS FOR BUNTING,
CARLSSON, SLIPPED AWAY  MINUTES.
FORE-CHECK KASE BEHIND,
YEARS.IT
FIRST TIME HE HAS BEEN IN A
FOURTH CONSERVATIVE FROM BOQVIS
KASEBLE
REACTION STOP.
BOQVIST CAN SHOOT THE
BACK TO THE POINT TO WERENSKI,
WITH SIX POWER PLAY GOALS THIS
YEAR. GOING TO TIP IN.
SHOOTS, SCORES!
[ Horn ].
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>> Gord: AUSTON MATTHEWS WITH A
>> Gord: WERENSKI, GOINGFT.
NOT SURE IF IT WAS TIPPEDK DANC.
PASS TO DOMI,
OPPORTUNITY WILL ARISE, AND WHAT
THE OPPORTUNITY WILL COME CENTR
ICE AND THAT CENTRING PASS IS
WIDE.
KASE WITH IT. IT,
NOW ROBINSON, BACK-TO-BACK TO M
STEEVES TRIES TO HOLDCKS IT DOW.